my story consists of a lot of drug using
a lot of prostitution a lot of street
living and a lot of criminal
this is what my story consists of
darnell where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i grew up in a city
outside of san francisco called
pittsburgh south side of oakland
between frisco and oakland uh i'm 48
years old
at this time tell me about your family
my family i have two sisters one brother
my mom died in 217.
uh that's all that's left it's just me
two sisters and one brother
how was your childhood it was pretty
rough it was pretty bad i grew up in the
projects
in uh pittsburgh uh from i think
we got there in 1972. in 1972
i think i was five six years old seven
something like that
and uh one of my mother's boyfriends
uh he had a tendency of keep looking at
me all the time because i was a little
guy
first of all and he felt that you know
that i was a guy that
maybe he wanted to try but anyway to
move right along
uh i was molested by him three times
i never told my mother until two years
later
i finally you know told her exactly what
he had done
and you know she didn't accept it
because she didn't believe me
because i waited so long to tell
so that kind of stuck with me for a long
time and as i got older
i just couldn't trust people i couldn't
trust especially men's
that were older than me i couldn't trust
them i couldn't be around them i could
stay in a room too long with them
because i was scared i was really afraid
uh as time went on
i i alienated myself because
of that fact i started using drugs at
13.
my first choice of drugs was alcohol and
from alcohol
i started using cocaine i i didn't smoke
anything i just put it in my nose and i
didn't get an effect
and i always thought about it like what
what does it does
so it really didn't do anything for me
so as time went on
by the time i was 15 i learned about
freebasing
back then they called it free spacing
and uh this girl showed me how to
freebase and i learned about the
freebase
and at that time whenever i ran out of
money i went out and i
sold my body to get the money for the
freebase
uh that went on for a couple of years
maybe three years
and then after that i did my first
prison term by the time i was 17 years
old
i did a prison turn for uh breaking an
injury
and uh robbery stealing stealing money
from an old guy he was a trick
and i stole some money from him and i
ran off and he called the police on me
anyway
i did time for that uh i did until i was
22 years old from 17 to 22 i got out
and you know my criminology had advanced
now i know how to do a lot of things so
i started boosting
i started running with crowds that you
know shot dope
and you know i got introduced to heron
and and
from heron it just took me to a whole
nother phase
because heroin is a drug that you have
to have it
you cannot go a day without it so i had
to go and plan my day
every day i had to have my dope at night
and i had to plan my day
during the day to go get money for my
dope at night and i did that for four
and a half years
straight no breaks no nothing uh
i started you know coming to a point to
where
i started getting sick you know where i
couldn't
eat i couldn't sleep i couldn't do
anything i didn't even think right
so i stopped showering i stopped you
know taking care of my hygiene i stopped
doing a lot of things
i became a full-fledged junkie and
i i started sleeping on abandoned houses
and whatever i
was able to get me a fix i did it
whatever it took
to get it i did it i did that for years
uh by the time i was 25 years old
i had become uh someone that what they
would call
what the law would call a a full-fledged
criminal
you know i had started you know doing
all kinds of things
forgery burglary uh uh robbery
uh all kind of things i was doing to get
my fix
because i'm a full-fledged heroin addict
and i went through that for six years
until i was 32 years old
and i did another prison term and i
cleaned up
because i did five years in prison so i
kind of cleaned up
and when i came home and i told myself
and i told my family
my siblings they're still here with me
today that i will not use
any drugs no more in my life that lasted
about seven months uh i meet a female
at a club and she had some coke
and i let her do her thing i didn't
touch it
and on the way home she told me you
spend a night we're gonna do some coke
then we kick back
and i went into and i tried some coke
and i ended up wanting more because coke
is a trigger
for heroin so once i tried the coke
and i told her well i need something
more can we go get it so
i found my way downtown uh i got some
hair on
and she had never messed with herron so
i introduced her
to the needle and from that point on for
eight days
me and her shot heroin and ran the
streets
uh she finally got arrested for
uh shoplifting and they put a
restraining order on me
i also got arrested too they put a
restraining order on me
where i could not have any deals with
her so i went in and i did
14 months on that case i got out
and i went straight to the dope dealer
it's it's it's it's really true
you know you're out by eight and you see
in the dealer by 12.
that's really true that happens in real
life
uh after i've seen the dealer i got me
some hair run
i laid on the curve i vomit everywhere
because i was sick
because i hadn't done it in a while and
you know your first dose
is very bad uh i laid there for
two days it's what i remember two days
people say i was there longer but i
remember two days
uh and i finally woke up and some guys
took me to a mission
uh they call it the la mission it's here
on fifth and uh
wall street i believe uh they took me
there
they put me in there i was supposed to
stay clean for 30 days
in order for me to treat the quartility
of the other mission
uh i think i lasted four days four days
after i ate and slept a couple of days
i was back on the streets and i sold my
body
and i went and i got me some heroin and
uh
at that time the guy that i sold my body
to he was infected he
he had hiv but so happened it didn't
affect me
for some reason i don't know because i
wasn't safe
i just did what i had to do and to get
my hair on
so as time went on you know i'm 36 years
old at this time
so as time went on i started finding
myself
not only tricking but i'm also letting
people
take me to mountains to it's
you know resorts uh hitaways
caves uh uh tunnels i'm doing all these
things
just to get my hair on uh one day one
one time i stayed in a cave
for nine days no heater no act no
nothing
and i didn't eat for six of them days
when i finally did eat something
i wasn't able to eat it because i hadn't
been accustomed to food at that time
so i wasn't able to eat it uh i
eventually got away from the guy
and i made it back down into the city
limits
and once i got to the city limits i met
a guy and he took me to las vegas
uh i ended up in vegas for 18 days with
this guy
uh he had me tricking with other guys
and he paid me twenty dollars each guy
so i i went through that as long as i
was able to get my hair on
i did that for uh 18 days
and i finally got away from here i ended
up in whiskey uh whiskey peak
uh i i found uh what they call a bravo
house
where you know women's gold and silly
bodies and you know they pay the house
so anyway i found one and it's for men's
so i ended up staying in a bravo house
about i think uh four and a half months
i i you know i paid my ties i did my
tricks
and i went out and got my hat run i did
that for four and a half months
and uh they finally bust me one time i
had heroin in the room
and they kicked me out so i now down in
whiskey peace in nevada
uh running around with just heroin in my
possession
and no money so i found a guy that had a
mobile home
uh he let me stay in his mobile home for
eight days
while i give him drugs as long as i was
able to give him drugs
i was able to stay there once i ran out
of
funds to get drugs i had to go into the
city
and do some things to get drug so i went
in and
at this time uh they had a sting
operation going on
with male prostitution and i didn't know
because i was sick and i just wanted
drugs
so i went in a bar matter of fact the
name of the club is monte carlo it's the
casino
i went in here and i met the guy he took
me up to his room
and you know as soon as i told him about
the price and everything
they came in and they arrested me so i
ended up doing
uh 32 months in nevada behind
male prostitution so uh i get out of
that
now i'm pressing 40. i'm 48 now so this
is
i'm turning 40 now at this time and
i haven't changed nothing i haven't
changed nothing
i i still have the same mentality i
still have the weight it's the same way
of thinking
and and you know i just didn't change
anything and at this time i'm 36 years
old
and i'm still doing the same thing you
know uh
i don't know too many people that have
survived
that length of time but i you know i
don't know if it was god
i don't know what it was but i survived
now i'm in
nevada and i'm stuck i'm stranded i
don't have
nowhere to go but i have drugs so
i walk around i find little places to
sit
and shoot my dope i did that for my
first night
the second night i woke up i was sitting
on the curve
and it was raining and i was sick
because i
had ran out of drugs now i'm about maybe
22
23 miles from this las vegas boulevard
the city of las vegas so now i either go
what back that way
or i go the other way towards los
angeles so i chose los
angeles i started hitchhiking i meet a
guy
and his wife on the highway uh
back to los angeles and their groupies
they like to have sex with each other
and they like for
guys to watch them have sex and their
pay
so i needed dope so i made the guy
i basically what i did i kidnapped both
of them
and made them drive me to los angeles
before we do anything
so i can get my drugs so once i got to
los angeles i ended up on fifth
and crocker and i got me a gram of dope
and i did my dope and me and this couple
went renting a room and we was in the
room
for 11 days uh doing what we do
you know sexting each other partying
eating food
throwing stuff around not showering not
doing any
things that normal humans does we didn't
do any of that
so as that passed uh i finally got to
the point where i robbed them
i you know they fell asleep one night
and they had travels checks
and a few uh currency so i took
everything
and i left i ended up on san pedro
at six uh i went out and bought me a
tent
and i sat in my tent for 18 months
shooting heroin
uh a partying doing anything you know
doing the things
that criminal street people does i did
that
so now it's 2017. this is another year
uh i went out to buy some heroin
and the police followed me to the place
to buy the drugs because they knew me
from me
running around downtown all day every
day
so they had a good familiar of me
and they followed me to the dealer and
they ran in
and as soon as the dealer gave me the
package and i gave them the money
they ran in and they arrested everybody
they took me to jail
uh i did another two years uh two
well two and a half years on that case i
got out
2019 february uh
i was out for four days and i needed
some heroin because
i have been missing it for almost two
and a half years
i don't know why i needed it because i
was i did without for two and a half
years but i still
in my mind and my craving being here on
the streets
is a trigger for me so when i seen the
streets
and everything was still the same i
needed some heroin
and i went and got me some heroin uh
february
of 2019 and i got to her on i sat there
i did my drugs on the streets uh it's a
little place called fresh start
uh i did it in front of there i did my
dope and i i passed out
i basically od okay uh once i came to
they i was in a hospital with ivs all
over me
when and you know i just couldn't take
it and i snatched all that stuff out
and i walked out with a gallon on i left
all my property
everything because i needed some more
hair on so i ended up back on fifth and
crocker
to get me some more hair on and i got
some more heroin
and at that time i had hemorrhoids
stealing the needle
in my arm with me tied up and passed out
again
at this time it was the police that
talked stopped me
and came to me and took me to jail for
under the influence
okay my record shows that i'm a heroin
user i'm a dope dealer i'm a forger i'm
a burglar
i'm all kind of things so the district
attorney
told me the only way they're going to
put me in the program
if i do a year in the county jail first
and then they will put me in the program
i recently did a year in the county jail
i was released
uh march the 3rd 2020
and this is the end of my story all
right
darnell thank you very much do you have
do you have kids zero excuse me do you
have any children
no i don't know no kids and you've been
out how many days
two days two days later what's the day
today's friday
i mean what's the date today's today is
march uh
sixth i gotta i've been out three days
three days get out with that
so i haven't no no no i'm not so jail is
a great way to get clean right
that's the only way i get clean so
you're clean right now yes i've been
clean for three days
well
no [ __ ] so so what do you think the
chances are of you staying clean though
well i'm gonna use the resources i'm
gonna i'm gonna work that
get the [ __ ] out of this neighborhood
exactly i'm to use the resources
you're going to send me to a program
that's in semi valley
so i've never been out there i don't
know anything about it
i'm going there i'm going there uh
monday monday day center i mean
it's like you haven't had sex for three
years and you're in a brothel yeah you
just get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm gonna go man you gotta get out of
here dan right now
i gotta i got a lot more to go with that
but i just wanted to
give you the basics yeah yes no but i'm
just worried about your next
move yeah hey it's been good my three
days
i've stepped in tents for the three days
people coming and using drugs and i it
didn't bother me
so i i know i'm on a good page do you
have any family you can go to or
nothing here nothing nothing here what
what about elsewhere excuse me what
about elsewhere other cities oh yeah i
have i have an auntie in ohio
and i have someone in texas and my
sisters and brothers are in texas
yeah yeah i mean maybe maybe relying on
some family for a while just to well
they told me if i can clean up you know
if i can stay clean while i'm on the
streets
not why i'm in jail this is the only
thing that my sisters and brothers don't
like
i can't clean in jail no i anybody can
yeah you know when i'm on the streets
they tell me you stay clean for six
months i will send you a plan ticket
bring you here and give you a job this
is what my sister said yeah they're
they're right too
and they're right man yeah they are they
are right there they're smart you know
i went out i bought me some new shoes i
never done this i spent my money on
heroin man
i went out and bought shoes yesterday i
bought pants i bought a shirt
i did this i didn't spend my money on
her i could feel
so i know i'm on a good page i know
that not only him but my heart is
telling me
try it just try it and see how far you
can go with it i mean all you gotta do
is walk up and down these streets and
see what the
man it's just when i ran into him i was
going out he was like wait
you got someone to sleep tonight i said
no so i'm just gonna kick it he said
look
come on i got somebody i want you to
talk to man you want to get your story
up your chest
i said i shared my story before in the
aaa he said no
you can get your story off your chest
for real
so that's why you brought me here cool i
i don't know i wish you luck and
uh i hope you get get the hell out of
here as fast as possible
i don't care because you got to be three
times ten times as strong to
to resist here because it's every every
ten feet
you know last night i stepped in a tent
and every 20 minutes
someone was coming over there yeah and
all i did was pull the blanket over my
head
i mean you walked on any block there's
what there's 25 tenths on that block
every single one of those tents it's
either heroin correct
christmas it's really good real function
disease
man yeah it's a functioning disease for
the ones that
i mean it's bad i seen it last night i i
mean
every 20 minutes i'm just saying 20
minutes it might have been sooner than
that
but someone was coming in uh uh and he
was like
can he could he sit down can they sit
down i like go ahead i just want to go
to sleep
yeah and they did they think they did
their thing and i can hear it
i can hear their moans and hiding i can
hear
everything and it's see you you know
a heroin junkie is a person that
he feels the power once he gets it
he's weak as a puppy without it
but once he gets it it's like superman
man it's like the the
the the the kryptonite is gone you're no
longer
sitting around the krypton you are back
with your strength
and then when you put it in there you
even get stronger
in in in and not physically not even
mentally
it's just something that you think that
something that you just
run through your mind like ah you know
and i heard that last night man
from different people sitting down doing
it and that's something that i did for
years
and i always look for that it's
something that you chase you want to get
that first feeling you know and i you
know and i was strong enough
to take that blanket and cover over my
head and i really went to sleep
and i woke up this morning i went and
bought my shoes and i felt good man
yeah and i ain't feel good like this
being on the streets
in a long time i hope you stay strong in
a long time man stay strong dude
all right i appreciate you know just you
taking my story in man
you know love you for that good luck
okay thank you
thank you
you